an Arizona man is in custody for a
string of killings that terrorized the
Phoenix area for about a year police say
that 23 year old Aaron saucedo is the
gunman known as the serial street
shooter he was arrested yesterday in
connection with nine killings and a
total of 12 shootings the crimes date
back to 2015 Carter Evans is outside the
Phoenix Police Department headquarters
Carter good morning now police say ala
saucedo
was picked up last month in connection
with another deadly shooting in 2015
that was the killing of his mother's
boyfriend but in this case police say it
was help from the community 33,000 tips
in all led them straight to the
suspected shooter it's been said that a
serial killer is like a chameleon and
that's what made this case so
frustrating police in Arizona believed
23-year old Aaron Saucedo is the serial
shooter law enforcement agencies have
been searching for for over a year
Salcedo was rebooked into the Maricopa
County Jail for 26 additional felony
counts including multiple counts of
homicide aggravated assault and drive-by
shootings
authorities say Saucedo is suspected in
connection with nine murders in the
Phoenix area dating back to 2015 police
believe he knew only one of the victims
all of whom appeared to be targeted at
night and ranged in age from just 12
years old to 61
the rest are believed to be attacked at
random in their cars or outside their
homes saucedo is the primary suspect no
evidence has indicated to us that there
are any associates involved in this case
police use forensics ballistics and
surveillance video to link saucedo to
the shootings but why he did it remains
a mystery you know don't have that
question Mike who was it who could it
have been are they gonna get him Lydia
Lopez his son Jesse Ola Vaz was shot and
killed near his home last January I'm
grateful to God that you know they
caught him you know he's
he's stopped now he's not going to hurt
other people and I have closure now at
this time police say saucedo is not
connected to those freeway shootings
that happened here back in 2015 as for
saw shadows case the district attorney
is now deciding what charges to pursue
all right Thank You Carter